yeah next speaker is yulung Choi who
will talk us tell us about probabilistic
reasoning and learning for trustworthy
AI
um hi my name is Yu Jong Choi coming
from Arizona State University where I
joined as an assistant professor last
fall uh before that I did my PhD at UCLA
and I'm visiting Simon's this semester
for the logic and database and AI
program
um so today I thought I'd talk about
kind of broadly what what I'm interested
in and in particular how we can use
these um probabilistic models that have
some some nice theory behind them to to
solve some problems in a trustworthy AI
domain
so uh some examples
um some example questions that I'm
thinking about when I say trustworthy Ai
and ml issues
um
we often see that ai-based decisions can
kind of exacerbate uh bias that's in the
data so fairness issues are also kind of
um
um something that that a lot of people
are getting interested in so for example
um one one simple way to to ask this is
if you're given
um if you're given some some AI system
making decisions that are actually
affecting people
um how fair or like how how different
those decisions are across different
demographic groups
um if you have a particular prediction
model you might ask why was that a
particular decision made explain
um that this particular decision you
could also ask
um if you're for instance making like
medical diagnosis
um you need to like make decisions
sometimes with uh partially available
records you might be wondering you know
how robust are these decisions
and um my view
um in my research is that
a lot of these uh questions to some
extent can can all be written as
probabilistic questions right so a very
simple uh sort of notion of fairness
that people look and look into is
essentially just comparing what is the
expected or like average decision
um made by by an AI model across
different demographic groups and
comparing if there's a discrepancy in
that the average outcome
um you could for example
um ask for
um ask you know how robust some decision
made with missing values are by looking
at
um
how how much that decision will change
if if you consider all the possible um
ways that missing those missing values
can be completed According to some
distribution
so because um you can formulate
these questions as a probabilistic
queries
what I'm interested in is actually sort
of capturing that like underlying
distribution where you'll want to deploy
the system
as the probabilistic model
and then
um we want to reason about a given sort
of machine learning models behaviors
through probabilistic inference
and what's nice about this is
um if we can if we know how to write
down these uh different questions and
interests for the AI domain as uh
problems like inference task then as
long as we can we make a good choice
about the model and and the inference
engine we can answer a lot of this this
questions through this single framework
so for that we need to be careful in how
we're choosing the model and and
inference algorithms so first we want to
choose a model where we can compute uh
various often they're very hard uh
problems like queries efficiently and
and for now
um let's just focus on actually
answering them exactly and efficiently
because um
the motivation was regarding like
trustworthiness and reliability so let's
first look at when we can actually
answer these exactly
um and we want to choose a model that
allows us to answer these queries
um while still representing a you know
complex real world uh distributions
and um I said you know underlying
distribution
which means not just capturing whatever
data we're seeing but really
um handling for example different
uncertainties that you might not be able
to see just straight from data right
um especially in domains where the
fairness might be an issue sometimes you
can't trust the data there might be um
you know historical bias in the data you
may have bias that or noisy
on data so so the goal really is to to
capture that underlying distribution
through a model that will allow us to
answer
um various probabilistic inference tasks
so
um in this talk I'll
sort of
um tell you about the model that I like
for this framework which is um called
probabilistic circuits so if
um people who are at the the boot camp
couple weeks ago might be it might
um remember the the talk on property
circuits are all kind of
um give a high level overview of what
these models are about
um and then I'll give one example of how
we can use them to to um address some
algorithmic fairness issues
okay so what are these uh models
probabilistic circuits at a very high
level you can just view this as a um
computational graph that's that's
recursively defining distributions
so at the very base level you have a
single for instance a universe that's a
that's a simple distribution
now the idea is we can combine
um
distributions recursively to Define more
and more complex ones so a weighted sum
or or a convex combination of of uh
distributions is also this probably
probability distribution you can
multiply distributions to obtain another
distribution over a larger set of
variables
and the idea is that we combine this
recursively to get to capture more and
more complex distributions
right
so um when it comes to actually
um
Computing for example probabilities out
of these models it's very simple I said
it's a computational graph so all you
have to do is when you want to compute
some probability uh given given some
values for for your variable you just
plug those values in at the leaves and
then just
um
to do a feed forward evaluation
following
um following the synaptics given by the
computational graphs so you're starting
from the um from the leaf just Computing
weighted sums and products until you get
some Value method which gives you the
probability for for that specific
values that you gave as input
so that's that's all simple so far this
is just something products that are
nested
um why is this special
um so earlier I said we we want a model
we want our model to answer different
probabilistic questions efficiently okay
so what's nice about them is
we can start
enforcing some structural constraints on
the circuit and that allows us to
actually answer different query classes
in polynomial time in the size of the
model and often this will be actual
linear time so it's it's actually quite
fast in in practice
um without really going into detail what
the what the constraints actually look
like so so one example I think was
um mentioned in michalasago is also like
the composability
um so if you're given these properties
that that make essentially sums and
products behave nicely like mixtures or
factorizations if you're familiar with
these terms then basically we can
compute any marginal probability
basically compute um arbitrary
Integrations in linear time in the size
of the circuit and all we're doing is
again given some values plug those
values in at the leaves
um and then for the variables that you
want to integrate out just plug in the
marginals at the leaves again do a field
forward evaluation just Computing
weighted sums and products and
at the root we get our marginal property
and and you can do this
um for arbitrary you know integrals
whatever variables you want to
marginalize out it's essentially the
same field for uh evaluation
okay so we can compute
um some some queries efficiently and the
idea is going to be depending on what
queries you care about we can Define
um what circuit properties you need to
actually compute that efficiently
um
so to actually give an example
um in the fairness domain
so the problem we considered here is
um
we are trying to learn a classifier
but the labels that we're given is not
actually the true Target that we want to
predict
so this might occur for instance if
you're trying to
um make let's say hiring decisions if
you want to you know so the goal is to
to predict someone's job performance
let's say so that's like a latent
variable that's inherently kind of hard
to
um represent often what you get is like
a historical data of you know employee
uh reviews or previous uh promotion
records
so in an Ideal World these should be the
same same variable
um
but in in practicing in real world data
they're you know very closely correlated
but often not equal
so the setting is given that we are we
just see the observed like uh historical
promotion record
can we infer uh something about the
hidden uh through Target variable which
in this case was actually that person's
uh job performance
and we're going to do this by
um
explicitly encoding the fact that
what we're seeing in in the data the
labels that we're seeing are biased
versions of the true Target that is
actually hidden
so we're going to encode that in our
probabilistic model and then use
inference to
um uncover these hidden Fair labels
so we'll all kind of give a very sort of
high level uh idea like I said we are
going to
um explicitly you know encode the fact
that there there is a hidden Fair label
that we're actually not seeing the data
so this just becomes like a latent
variable that we are introducing on on
our model on top of all the variables
that we see in the data okay
so this is just some latent variable we
introduced in the model we need to give
it a proper meaning we need to make sure
that this actually is the the um Fair
label and the labels that we are seeing
in in data is some somehow like a noisy
or biased versions of that
sparing you you so the the details
basically this can be done by
um
um in enforcing some group fairness on
this latent uh they can variable
which in the case of probability
classifier basically ends up being some
a couple of Independence assumptions
about the distribution
and given the the Sim the recursive
semantics of the circuit we can actually
encode this kind of assumption
um as a hard constraint on on the
circuit
actually by fixing some structure in a
clever way right so in
um whatever distribution we get out of
out of the circuit we are guaranteed
that the independence assumptions we
wanted will hold
given those assumptions we're going to
learn the The Joint distribution over
all the variables including the the
latent variable
um in a way that best explains explains
the data
so we could use this to
um make predictions about the hidden
label
um
you could also for instance
um use this to take some data and then
clean it up by for um by inferring what
the hidden label should have been for
each data sample based on based on the
observations uh you see
how this can be used as is essentially
because we can infer these stock
condition probably is very efficiently
um we can clean the data efficiently and
then fit it into some some uh down
Downstream tasks to for instance given
some arbitrary classifier
um
probabilistically a reason about how
fair that that classifier is with
respect to this hidden uh Fair labels
and also enforce other Notions of
fairness on on that um hidden label
um let me wrap it up uh real quickly
um so
in addition to this kind of trustworthy
AI problems to develop a framework I'm
also really interested in in
um how we can characterize this
distractible inference and push it
further
um
like I said earlier this uh sort of
involves
for um for different queries
characterizing you know what
what circuit properties we might need to
actually answer those efficiently
um for interesting interesting queries
uh that that can be for different uh
complexities
and um
I'm also you know interesting how
interested in how we can push them
further how we can um kind of come up
with
on new inference algorithms for a given
query in a systematic way so without
having to start from scratch can we um
can we reuse as much as uh
could we use what we know as much as
possible and I'll kind of live this as a
teaser for that idea which was
um we can answer queries but um to try
to in trying to characterize how we can
answer queries efficiently we can
instead focus on those little components
that that go into answering the query
and characterize when we can do this
operations efficiently
which we can then you know compose like
Lego blocks to answer other other
queries
um
and yeah I'd be happy to also talk about
this more more offline but I'll just
leave this here as as a little diagram
of a reminder of that idea
thank you
[Applause]
good question if there's any
right so the final talk the meet the
fellows event so